[Music]
since the beginning of the pandemic
numbers are playing an even larger role
in our day-to-day lives
which is better standing 1.5 meters
apart
or two meters and what exactly is the r
rate do i have enough masks
and how long can i wear one for
numbers inform our decision making
how many kids can be safely in one
classroom
or how many people should i be allowed
to meet with
but with new and changing numbers coming
to us every day
what's important and how do you keep
your head from spinning
with so many statistics associated with
the coronavirus pandemic
it's impossible to keep on top of them
all or even to understand them
well if all these numbers are leaving
you numb allow us to help you out
by explaining a few of the key ones
the seven day incidents indicates how
many people tested positive within one
week
measured per 100 000 inhabitants
for example let's assume a city with 129
000 inhabitants has this number of
positive tests in one week
we add up all the positive test results
[Music]
and then the seven day incidence is
calculated 48 times a hundred thousand
divided by 129 000 inhabitants giving an
incidence of 37.2
the number allows you to ascertain the
current infection rate
in other words how many people are
currently infected in a region and since
it refers to 100 000 inhabitants one can
also say
so to speak what the percentage of new
infections is
a value is considered problematic for a
region once it becomes difficult to
identify
all contacts an infected person has had
in germany
that is a seven day incidence above 50.
the effective reproduction rate r
describes the average number of people
an infected person passes the virus onto
an r-value of two means that one
infected person
passes the disease to two others meaning
the virus
spreads exponentially
if the effective reproduction number is
less than one the number of new
infections decreases
[Music]
while the seven day incidence offers an
initial
estimate the reproduction rate gives you
an idea of the dynamics
how quickly the infection is currently
spreading from one person
to the
the next fatality rate indicates how
many people who tested positive
die from or with the virus
[Music]
if for example 1 out of 10 people dies
the case fatality rate is 10 percent
if we take a look at the latest case
fatality rates from different countries
we see a very inconsistent picture
with the world average hovering around a
case fatality rate
of 2.4
[Music]
the number is important for considering
how threatening the infection is
for an individual patient but it also
has
notable problems on the one hand the
number of
unreported cases is very important and
the number of undetected cases
also depends on how much testing is
going on in other words
you might get a distorted picture if you
test very much or very little
the problem with many of the key
statistics depending on your test
capacity the figures change
nevertheless the measurements provide
valuable information
in short it's about relative changes and
you can see those quite well in these
figures
and the goal remains the same all
through the pandemic to prevent
healthcare systems from becoming
overburdened
let's speak to maria barbarossa who is a
mathematician at the frankfurt institute
for advanced studies thanks for joining
us maria
so many numbers too many for anyone to
really
keep across so can you help us out here
is there
one number that we should be paying more
attention to than all the others
well um there are really many numbers
uh concerning the pandemic and there
have been many
coming across during the months we
are currently paying very much attention
to numbers which indicate the severity
of this disease like the hospitalization
and icu requirement
so people who are in severe conditions
because of this disease
and these are numbers to us which inform
us
a bit more about um the
severity and and the health care
requirement
rather that only numbers concerning the
detection so like
seven days incidence or rt number
so you say that's what you're currently
focusing on does the number
that's most important change over time
this this change of course um
we have been tracking them essentially
since the beginning of the pandemic it
became quite clear that the
disease require or might have a severe
course
and end up in debts or require
hospitalization and
health care and this is
of course an indicator which
which is not stable depends very much on
the on the
on the healthcare capacity of the
country but
i believe is less affected uh from
tracking capacities or testing activity
in the country so
we have all these numbers the r number
the seven day incidences and stuff
do the general public need to be across
these numbers i can understand
why governments and decision makers
might need to be but what about
can't we just stay at home and do as
we're told without getting caught up in
the figures
well i guess it's probably the first
time
um at least since i'm aware of that and
as far the first time that people became
so informed about
the the meaning of reproduction number
or even
seven days incident for any disease um
these numbers are reported for a number
of diseases but usually are kept in in
in control systems in healthcare
facilities so
people were working with that so now it
they went into the community and i guess
it was because
of making people aware making people um
aware of the severity of the pandemic of
of the
the way weight spreads um but of course
the the number of the numbers uh that we
get or the more numbers that we get
this can make people more confused they
might not know what they you're looking
at it's
there are some indicators like the
reproduction number
or which which is not like temperature
measurement
it depends on on on the cases that are
reported
and these are in case of covet for sure
not all cases which we have out there
yeah i suppose misunderstanding the
numbers could cause more problems than
not knowing them at all anyway maria
barbarossa thank you so much for
bringing us your expertise from the
frankfurt institute for
advanced studies thank you very much
now as the part of the program where you
get to ask the questions you've been
submitting them
through our youtube channel so now let's
put one of them to our science
correspondent
derek williams
should people who have already had
kovid19 continue to wear masks
i answered this question a few months
ago and the guidelines haven't really
changed but it gets sent in so often
that i guess it's it's maybe time for
a reminder the short answer is that a
lot of aspects of covid19 immunity
are still pretty hazy because people
simply haven't been recovering from it
long enough
to provide solid long-term data
based on what we've seen so far with the
disease people who get infected once
do acquire some immunity for a period of
time
the big problem is we still don't really
know how long on average
that period is so for some framework
it makes sense to look at what we know
about other coronaviruses
that infect humans and and studies there
have revealed that immunity can wane
pretty swiftly
a number of them convincingly show
people can be
reinfected with some of those pathogens
within a year of catching them once
so far there have been a few dozen
documented cases of that also
happening with covet 19 but as as
proving
reinfection is is quite a complex
challenge the real numbers
are almost certainly higher um in some
of the documented cases the people who
got it again
showed no symptoms the second time
around but but in others they got
the disease worse and we still don't
know
whether they were infectious to others
so
until we have better data guidelines
from health authorities like the cdc
recommends that you continue to wear a
mask especially in
indoor public spaces until we have more
information
you should assume that masking up is
still an effective way to protect not
only others
but yourself even if you've had covet 19
once
and recovered from it
[Music]
and you can submit a question for derek
through our youtube channel dw
news now i know we've already thrown a
lot of numbers at you in today's program
but bear with us here we have just a
couple of
more for you because with the vaccine
production starting up around the world
we asked you through our social media
channels
if you would take a jab against kovid
19. so here are the results
the largest proportion over 40 said
they'd rather wait and see
before taking a vaccine 38
said they are prepared to take the
vaccine and around
16 percent said they would not be
willing
to get immunized against kovid 19.
now cozy bears mentioning that
virologists say immunization is the only
way to get a grip
on the coronavirus pandemic but it seems
there is still a fair bit of skepticism
around the vaccines
we've seen developed in recent months